ενουν η εκπαιδευτική να διδάξου γιατί είχαν τόση πολύ νήλη δεν μπορολαβαίνουν να σταματήσουν να
κάνουν αναστοχασμό και να μιλήσουνε με τα παιδιά καν στη μέση εκπαίδευση εν ιδικά απου
έχουμε καια τι σε εξετάσεις άρα υτό κάναμε σταματήσαμε και είπαμε τι δεν χρειαζόμαστε να
το βγάλουμε και πέρσει μιλώντας με εκπαιδευτικούς διαδμιλομόνο με τους συνδικάλιστές μελό και με τη
βάσει αυτό ακούο και χαίρομε ότι για πρώτη φορά προλάβαμε την ήλι μαςαυτονόι τον έπρεπε
να ήταν αυτό για πρώτη φορά είχα χρόνο να μιλήσουμε τα παιδιά και να ζητήσω
απορείμες διαρωτούνται πολλά σφορες γιατί και εγώ όταν διαβάζουμε την κόρη μου που είναι στο
δημοτικό διαβάζωόταν βλέπομ να μέρως τη σύλη ερωτούμε γιατί το συμέζωστόν του παιδιου μάλισα μάλιστα
ντάξι βέβαια δεν είστε ιδικός για να πείτεε μπορεί να χρησιμεύσι αλλά μπορείτε αμέσως να
καταλάβεται ότι αυτό μπορεί να το βρει αλλού δεν χρειάζεται να αναλοφεί τόσος χρόνος λνε
ν για να παιδιά που πλέον είναι εξοικειωμένα σεδούτ ναι βέβαια α ολο ήμερα σχολία
και η σχεδιαςσχεδιασμεί είναι με το τέλος της διακυβέρνησης όλα τα δημοτικά να είναι ολοήμερα
σχολεία προαιρετικά διότι εξαρτάτε από το γονιώ αν το θέλειμε χριστρεις μεχριτιστές σερης η ίδι
έχουμε παραπάνωυ από τα μισά να λειτουργούνος προερετικά ολοημερα σχολεί απως ξέρετε και ιλοποιούμε και
να σχεδιασμό τριάντα περισσότερα φέτος εξύντα του χρόνουν σε γάσηχαμεριτογικόσι οκτώ θα έχουμε όλα τα
σχολία δημοτικής να είναι προορετικά ολοημέρα σημασία για μένα δεν έχει μόνο νο αριθμός έχει
και πιότητα τί κάνουν την ώρα πουμένου στο σχολείο γιατί τον απασχολήσει απλώς να κάνει
στα μαθήματα σουκαι να παίζεις μεχριναρτόν σε πάρουν οι γονίσοσουν δεν είναι μάθηση εμείς δια
συνδέουμε το ολογήμερο με το προινόσχολείο αραθέλουμε να γίνονται μαθήματα μαθήματα που να να μην
έχουν και οι διαίτερες όμως απετήσεις για τα παιδιά όστε να τα κουράζουμε πάρα πολύ
αποσ πληροφορική ι αγκλικά μαθήματα για τα οποία θα μπορεί να παρα καθήσει και σε
μια εξέταση αρά χτυπούμε και λίγο τοες